thank you
6 24 on your Monday morning say are you
still having trouble wrapping your head
around the Nevada Department of
transportation's I-15 trop project
so this view of trump in the 15 it's
looking south from Flamingo great way to
show one of the reasons for the upcoming
closure see the very start of the off
ramp to Trop that's coming down indot
says the current height of the incline
needs to be raised and yes the westbound
Lanes of trop from both sides of the
freeway they're also coming down
it's a fact the Tropicana closure
January 22nd through the 30th with an
I-15 closure thrown in there too now
once trop reopens both directions will
be sharing what had been the eastbound
Lanes to tell you to expect huge backups
there that ought to be a big incentive
to plan alternates now maybe Flamingo
maybe Russell well guess what that's
where a lot of drivers are going to go
so maybe shh try di or Harman or
Hacienda and maybe just download the
I-15 Tropicana app buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone you
can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com